[Música]
la guerra en ucrania continúa y france24
ha estado en el terreno en distintos
puntos del país para así recoger de
primera mano toda la información y es
que mientras las partes en conflicto
tratan de buscar una solución
diplomática a los ataques en suelo
ucraniano no paran los bombardeos
afectan directamente a la población
civil que sufre las consecuencias de la
guerra con miles de muertos y también
millones de desplazados hacer el
periodismo en el terreno en medio de una
guerra no es tarea fácil hay muchas
dificultades para trabajar en gran
medida por el difícil acceso a las
fuentes de información y para conocer
primera mano entonces cómo ha sido
cubrir todo este conflicto quiero
saludar en este momento a dos de
nuestras enviadas especiales hasta hace
poco estuvieron en el suelo ucraniano
estamos hablando de irene sabio y
leticia álvarez gracias a irena y
letizia por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 pues va a
ser una pregunta abierta y la que quiere
empezar el que comience a responderla
cómo ha sido trabajar en ucrania en este
momento de guerra además como dejaron el
país
buenos días
buenos dias letizia
ahora mismo es complicado en formar en
ucrania porque con la guerra
tenemos muchas restricciones
no nos dejan acercarnos en muchas
ocasiones al frente
confirmar con las fuentes es complicado
es verdad que nosotras junto con irene
llevamos cubriendo este conflicto desde
el 2014 y en ese aspecto tenemos
ventajas porque teníamos una red de
fuentes bastante consolidada pero pero a
día de hoy es complicado porque porque
la guerra de la propaganda es muy
importante también y bueno pues luego
por todo lo que lo que viene con la
guerra también que los problemas de
logística problemas de seguridad
irene todo tuyo
sí sí estoy de acuerdo que
nos ha ayudado mucho el trabajo de
equipo o sea nosotros somos dos
periodistas y es verdad que hemos
cubierto la crisis desde el 2014 y eso
nos ha ayudado mucho en
contactar las fuentes estén también
interpretar la realidad en tiempos más
breves pero los problemas de logística
los problemas relacionados con el
peligro que implica un conflicto armado
un conflicto armado en el que ya han
muerto lamentablemente colegas este es
evidente
y también nos ha afectado nos ha
afectado letizia mencionaba el tema de
la propaganda hay propaganda desde los
dos bandos y este es un obstáculo
bastante importante a la hora de manejar
la información es omnipresente realmente
en el día a día y también es casi
imposible no estar conectado y
sensibilizarse no de la mano con los
civiles con los ucranianos las personas
que están digamos sufriendo también
junto a ustedes digan es este tipo de
guerra estos bombardeos viendo
destruidos todos sus edificios su ciudad
viendo morir a sus familiares como ha
sido como cómo manejar esto para a pesar
de todos los sentimientos que uno puede
tener pues separar esto y hacer la labor
de informar el momento tan difícil tan
delicado como una guerra
es muy complicado es muy complicado
personalmente yo no fui consciente de la
magnitud de la guerra hasta el día en el
que empezamos a salir de kiev y
empezamos a vivir esa guerra con los
ciudadanos escapando nos de ella y
viviendo los bombardeos y pues para mí
ese fue un momento clave en la cobertura
porque era como una patada en el
estómago ver las caras de todas las
familias y compartir el terror el miedo
y es complicado aún así bueno es nuestro
trabajo y nos concentramos en informar
pero bueno te afecta de cómo le afecta a
ellos y yo creo que proceso también
enriquece una cobertura porque estar en
el momento donde pasa la noticia con la
gente afectada con los civiles para mí
es una de las cosas más importantes
digamos también irene uno conecta más te
sensibilizas más y entiendes más por el
problema que está pasando esa población
porque al final uno termina siendo parte
de esa población de encubrimientos como
éste
sí sí por supuesto de nuevo me encuentro
de acuerdo con leticia este realmente en
el momento en el que empezamos a evacuar
de kiev fue el momento en el que
realmente estuvimos
moviéndonos con estas personas en el que
coincidimos con con y con niños con
familias con ancianos que estaban
escapando desesperadamente y en muchos
casos ellos tuvieron los mismos
problemas que tuvimos nosotros de hecho
también nos hemos intercambiado
informaciones de cómo conseguir un lugar
donde un lugar donde resguardarse en las
noches cuáles serán las mejores rutas
por las cuales ir a las más alejadas de
los bombardeos los periodistas cuando
estamos en contacto directo con la
población yo creo que realmente le
podemos dar un aporte importante a
nuestras crónicas siempre manteniendo
esa objetividad que tenemos que intentar
mantener para dar la mejor información
posible y para que se pueda analizar la
situación también desde cierta distancia
que es creo también nuestra nuestra
misión
una excelente misión en el excelente
trabajo que han hecho ustedes dos
realmente desde aquí públicamente pues
las quiero felicitar por ese cubrimiento
que han hecho en esta guerra pero
también ustedes como lo decían al
principio han estado en las revueltas de
maidana lección a crimea y también en la
guerra el donbass esto cuando comenzó
todo en el 2014 que tanto ha
evolucionado cuál ha sido la diferencia
desde una ucrania y un dos bases de 2014
hasta ahora 2022
irene pues yo creo que en el terreno
nuestro trabajo ha evolucionado porque
como le decíamos en el comienzo
poder volver a un país en el cual ya se
tiene conocimiento se conoce la
geografía se conoce la cultura se conoce
la política el desarrollo de la crisis
en sí eso ayuda mucho a un periodista a
aterrizar con algunos recursos que le
permiten hacer su trabajo sobre todo una
forma más rápida
por otra parte el diría que la situación
de la seguridad
ha sido
ha ido empeorando para los periodistas
porque ahora el peligro realmente está
en todo el país mientras en esos años en
el 2014 2015 cuando empezó el conflicto
ma jian crimea dones realmente las
situaciones más difíciles se ve estaban
concentradas
en esos sitios donde se estaban llevando
a cabo los hechos en cambio en este
momento realmente hay que estar alerta
en todo en todo el país no sé si letizia
quiere añadir algo sobre el trabajo en
el terreno a partir de 2000 casi dice
que ella también lo ha cubierto mucho
bueno si el cambio es muy complejo
porque empezamos de unas revueltas en
maidán pasamos a haber una anexión como
crimea aterrizamos en una guerra en una
región solo y luego hemos terminado en
una guerra total o sea que los cambios
han sido muy grandes a nivel geopolítico
a nivel internacional a nivel personal y
a nivel de país que no tiene nada que
ver nuestra cobertura de maidán con lo
que acabamos de cubrir ahora que vamos a
seguir cubriendo no tiene nada que ver a
nivel de seguridad a nivel de
información eso completamente distintos
pero bueno es el comprender cómo nació
maidán es importante para saber por qué
estamos aquí ahora pues irene letizia
gracias por su tiempo gracias por
compartirnos su experiencia de haber
cubierto toda esta guerra en ucrania
además como ha sido la evolución no
hablamos desde 2014 hasta ahora la
actualidad nuevamente pues gracias y las
felicitaciones por él por el buen
trabajo que han hecho durante todo este
conflicto y pues esperemos en una
próxima oportunidad era normalmente en
este espacio france24 directo américa un
gran abrazo para las dos
sobre el apoyo